I find myself sitting on stage defending
insults
[Music]
I do completely take your point Miriam
about the fact that the cost people
living in stressful conditions is not is
not liable to produce you know
um erotic enjoyment uh people have
always shagged though you know in in in
in every possible era people have have
found ways to to have children in really
difficult circumstances
um and to have non-reproductive sex as
well
whereas there is something about
modernity because it's not just us right
it's not just the UK that's in the sex
recession I
East Asian countries like South Korea
and Japan are much more profoundly
affected by by this trend and we see it
across other developed countries and in
America and Canada and so on
there's something going on and I and I I
can't help but think that it just has
something to do with affluence
because that's the common theme across
all of those countries it's not to do
with
a particular religious tradition or
really any kind of unifying political
ideology even I mean I'm not sure if you
can really understand say Japan as being
a liberal country it's kind of it's so
it's so different it almost doesn't work
it but these these are all rich
countries
and is there may be something cost of
living accepted is there maybe something
about having an
something about late modernity which
makes people lonely and it's not just to
do with
um sexual relationships to do with all
kinds of relationships you know the
proportion of people who live on their
own
has gone up so steeply I was looking up
these figures last week just since the
1970s the proportion of people who live
on their own has doubled this is largely
a story of the elderly but it's also
Malaysian younger people who are living
on their own
I mean I really appreciate Zoe saying
that and and unwittingly maybe echoing
the words of Hugh Hefner he was once
asked
um
do you think how do you feel about the
dark consequences of the sexual
Revolution that you set and train and he
said it's the pro it's a price worth
paying for sexual freedom
and I think you know maybe it is maybe
that that is the choice that we're faced
with and maybe we should be honest about
it and say I guess we choose Freedom
maybe I was just this is my query with
all this I see a lot of people who
choose to opt out of hookup culture I
don't quite understand why there's this
idea that there is an I think there's
been a slippage here between real
regimes of control and just cultural
ones and I think like the fact that you
know and I and I am critical of the
whole like if I pull Dance I'm liberated
you know I I you know I choose my choice
and that's a politics no not probably
not but but I do think there's there's
something that bothers me about the
whole discussion I suppose which is this
idea that we are dupes we have no agency
we are living through false
consciousness
um to become like these like hook up
culture uh victims and you know we we
probably all do it is hard to sidestep
that I mean there is such thing as
cultural pressure and and so there is
there is there are scar tissues that
develop and baggage it develops but I
think it's a bit more comp it's a bit
more nuanced than hookup culture has
come along and destroyed you know all
these things I think a lot of people are
finding other ways to do things
um but I just want to say I think that
the big word we might be missing here is
the I word the internet which I think
has definitely played to me there's a
sort of dynamic
um there's a certain kind of sensibility
shift that occurs when you spend enough
time of your time
um you know doing whatever different
social media platforms including dating
apps require of you and the thing that
I've always noted about dating app
Behavior recently or in the last you
know however many years
um I only started
researching looking on dating apps after
I did an M fill all of that online
dating so I should get over but that was
the year Tinder launched but there's a
kind of jadedness and I think this thing
I actually don't agree that it's um so I
think I think certain internet formats
breed a kind of what we all know that
but I don't think that it's about rich
countries I don't think it's about
affluences this issue I think it's about
genuinely
liberal countries like we are a
politically liberal country and that
therefore leads to a Marketplace in
which there is plenty so as soon as you
have plenty sexual plenty say one of the
countries in the world where dating apps
are the biggest sellers in China which
many things but certainly not a liberal
country but it is a place where people
are basically finding that actually in
also a Place full of urban anime with
new cities springing up you know every
five minutes they can't find and in a
world you know of one one child policy
so much pressure to get married for
women I mean I don't think it is yeah
those the dating apps but I would I
would guess that the the experience of
that that that J did sense of
overabundance that we are talking about
would play out differently in an
environment where women are under a huge
stress to get married and to and to make
an economic decision we we don't quite
have that so I think it is probably
different by yeah but sorry just this
idea of abundance I have to like push
back as a woman or like undating apps is
there an abundance from a male
perspective of course there is they're
flipping through like who can I if
you're actually looking for anything
more than that which I think by and
large women do there's a study that came
out last year looking at like
satisfaction rates for casual sex
amongst men and women and I mean I I
thought I'd bring them out because it
just was very interesting to me so
casual sex generally leads to more
positive emotional outcomes for men than
for women anyone surprised probably not
but both reports engaging in both
reporting engaging in sexual in casual
sex but women are more likely to report
feeling miserable lonely and pressured
and having more negative outcomes like
loneliness and unhappiness and rejection
men are more likely to report positive
emotional outcomes with casual sex the
report concludes that women are engaging
in casual sex in the hope of finding a
partner men are engaging in casual sex
in the hope of finding several Partners
there is a stark difference when we
swipe we're hoping for the one they're
hoping for the many it's abundant for
them no I I I I I just don't
I just don't think that's true that as a
generalization yeah of course it's not
everything but I think there's
definitely something I'm not going to
deny that I think you're right that that
casual sex I mean this is there's
nothing new about that plays out
differently for men and women that's
true but I think
so much in the narrative me to pose me
to me too narratives assumes that women
can never be driven by desire alone like
for women it must always be attached to
this bigger emotional edifice of
commitment and I I do struggle with that
I think who are we to know there is
there is if you really don't believe
there's such thing as autonomous female
desire that can exist as a kind of thing
that needs to be dealt with and that
that's only a masculine thing I I just
don't think that's that I don't think
that's true I it doesn't mean that women
should therefore have to experience
callous callousness and bad treatment
which I think does happen more as a
result of hookup culture but my concern
about this idea like imagine we had this
world or potential Utopia where we got
rid of dating apps and we got rid of
casual sex
and this idea that women will wait until
there's the one so many women do not
find the one and then are they supposed
to just be numbs but no no hold on
you're confusing sexual desire on this
occasion with having a orgasm
which is a big difference like on this
occasion women going for casual hookups
by and large we know you're not getting
your dues you're not you're not they're
getting theirs you're not getting yours
so as a rule we're not getting ours so
we are looking for someone who's
invested enough to actually want to do
the work necessary to deliver the goods
and unfortunately the truth is many of
you don't I want to bring in Louise here
because apart from the US Lewis is
actually written an entire book which is
taking issue with many aspects of the
sexual sexual Revolution as is emerged
particularly in Britain since the 1960s
is the conversation you're hearing
Louise between uh Miriam and Zoe one
that strikes a chord with the thesis
that you've put forward
uh very much so and I think also that
the two positions are reconcilable
absolutely to the extent that obviously
individual preference varies a great
deal in there I I mean
average differences in
um sociosexuality so that's your desire
to have casual sex
the two bell curves the male and the
female one they overlap
very very horny people are much more
likely to be male and vice versa but
clearly there's
there are a lot of individual exceptions
that I will but also at the population
level you're completely right say that
that is really evident in hookup culture
um it's worth saying I find myself
sitting on stage defending insults it is
worth saying that actually most men do
not experience hyper abundance on dating
apps because
the the nature of how dating apps
operate is that women tend to be as a
rule lots of exceptions yada yada throat
clearing women tend to be more drawn to
status than our men
um and men tend to be more drawn to
looks than States so men are basically I
mean we all know the stereotype of the
the ugly rich guy with the gorgeous wife
there's there's a reason that that
stereotype exists because it does to
some extent
demonstrate slightly different drives
among men and women and it means that
women for instance are are more likely
to on dating apps accumulate their their
likes towards the most high status men
on the apps and ignore the sort of
bottom 90 so I think the figure on
Tinder is it's a 10 most attractive men
are getting 60 of likes
um so they are experienced absolutely
they are experiencing hyper abundance
and they are also experiencing a social
environment in which they can basically
do what they want yeah and there are no
real consequences and obviously
contraception means in Practical terms
there are no consequences and also
socially there are no consequences from
ghosting from all of these things which
the internet enables
because you're now able to basically
pluck out strangers from your 10 mile
radius in a huge City like London and
you never have to see them again you
have so you have no social connection to
them
cheating therefore becomes much easier
because you don't have to cheat with
people that you actually have any social
connection with so you can get away with
it you know there are all sorts of bad
behaviors which are definitely enabled
by the apps there are also bad behaviors
that 90 of men actually don't really
have access to even if they would even
if they might like to because they're
not getting as much attention as they
would hope and this is of course why we
part of the reason why we have all of
these young men who are
um remaining virgins not having
relationships feeling very
feeling very unhappy about it and I
think often being unfairly maligned as
political extremists or whatever when
many of them are just unlucky could I
just come in with a counter-intuitive
question which maybe you can't do
because it it doesn't have any basis but
just to ask Louise
is there any social good overall that
you could see from the statistical
reality that seems to be emerging that
at least in the UK in the 2020s people
are having young people having less sex
than would have been the case with their
predecessor Generations is there any
upside to it at all well there's also a
lot less teen pregnancy
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas